3 weeks ago I uploaded my first video on
this channel. Today, it has 10%
click-through rate, 50% retention, and
over 10,000 views. Now, it's time to
show how you can do that yourself.
Making three videos, maybe I'm just
making them on my phone and speaking to
the camera, and uploading them to a new
YouTube channel.
Aiming to make between 25 and 50 videos.
you have to make a certain amount of
videos before you find your niche.
This is terrible advice. I mean, it's
the way to go if you know nothing about
YouTube. Don't get me wrong, but if you
already have a channel, decent knowledge
about editing videos, thumbnails, things
like that, and you want to take the next
step or start a new channel, publishing
consistently or putting out a random
video without any planning is the worst
thing to do. It would work 2 years ago
since the algorithm wasn't pushing our
first video anyways, but now, that just
means wasting your biggest chance to
grow. You can completely blow up right
in your first video, like this channel,
and this, and this, and many more.
Well, how to do that? What makes a video
blow up? Obviously, you can't use the
regular way for this. You need to choose
the extreme way. Although the YouTube
algorithm has changed a lot, it still
wants just two things. Make people click
and make people watch. So, basically,
you need a good video idea, good title
and thumbnail, good editing, and a good
story. You must spend as much time as
you can on each of these to make a video
that connects with your audience. First,
you have to learn this one because
what's the point of making people click
if your video isn't worth watching for
You need to master the skill of getting
people's retention before getting them
to click on your video. So, let's get
started. I'm going to be honest. Before
starting this channel, I had no idea how
to use a story in my videos. I watched
tons of explainers about that. Everyone
was talking about storytelling, how
important it is, and all that. But
nobody was telling how I should actually
use it in my video. Every video just
told, "Okay, if you want more retention,
you should tell a story. It must have a
beginning, middle, and end." That's it.
But this formula is just too broad to
actually use with no experience. How am
I going to start the story? What should
I include in the middle? What about the
ending? But what if the storytelling is
easier than you think? So, I started
searching for something else. And one
day I came across this graph.
This is the strategy that almost every
successful channel is using. The best
part is, no matter your niche, you can
use it in your video. And it's simpler
than it looks. If you fill all the gaps,
you get a perfect storyline for your
video. And if you master this technique,
people will watch longer, and this
number will go up. So, I decided to give
it a try, made this video, and published
on this brand new channel.
Let me show you how it works. Well, as
you can see, it's a cycle. The journey
begins and ends on this side, called the
ordinary world. But to reach the end,
you still go through a special world.
There are 12 points you need to pass
along the way. To explain each step,
I'll take my favorite animation, How to
Train Your Dragon, as an example. But
the same thing applies to almost all
movies and YouTube videos you've seen.
If you give your full attention and
apply this method in your next video,
that will make people care about it and
watch way longer. Anyways, here's how
this movie did it using that formula.
But you got to focus. Status quo. You
see the Viking island, a community of
warriors led by this guy, and our main
character, Hiccup, a small Viking who
struggles to fit in. So, you should
introduce your main character here. Easy
peasy, right? Moving on. Call to
adventure. A dragon called Night Fury
attacks the Viking island. Hiccup wants
to prove himself to his dad and decides
to hunt down that dragon. You should
briefly explain why you're doing this
video and maybe show them what's to
come. Assistance. But one day, he sees
Night Fury in a forest and discovers
that dragons aren't the monsters they
believe. It wouldn't be interesting to
watch if your character knows everything
from the beginning. So, it's nice to add
someone more experienced or a source of
knowledge to the story for help.
Departure. Hiccup decides to go against
the Vikings and instead of fighting with
them, he tries to understand dragons.
That's the breaking point of the journey
where you step into the unknown, start
the challenge, or whatever your video is
about. The adventure starts. Trials. He
tries to convince his father and the
rest of the Vikings who still see
dragons as enemies, but they don't
listen to him. These are some barriers
that separates you on your way to the
video's main goal. Just add some spice
and action to the story. Approach. Here,
you may show a teaser of the biggest
threat in your video. While hanging out
with his friend, Hiccup discovers a
gigantic dragon that controls all the
other dragons. Crisis. The Vikings learn
that and go for a fight with But they
underestimate its power and almost lose
it all. This is the darkest point of the
story. Your character faces the biggest
challenge and gets defeated so badly.
But then he finds something.
Hiccup realizes that they can't defeat
this thing without joining the force
between humans and dragons. For your
video, this treasure can be a new idea,
a motivation, or support from a friend.
Result. With that treasure, you overcome
the crisis and achieve your goal for the
video. The Vikings use dragons to defeat
the big guy. Return. After all that
crazy adventure, it's time to return to
the ordinary world. You can either bring
all that treasure with you or lose it
all along the way. In the movie, they
managed to defeat the giant, but Hiccup
is gets injured in the process. New
life. As you can understand from the
name, your character should have some
kind of new life at this point. Maybe he
went from poor to rich, unhealthy to
fit, and so on. Hiccup survives, but the
battle leaves him with a prosthetic leg.
The Vikings celebrate their victory, and
dragons are accepted as part of their
community. Resolution. Hiccup becomes a
hero in the eyes of the Vikings. They
now understand the value of living with
dragons. Status quo. Everyone adopts a
new way of life where Vikings and
dragons live side by side, leading to a
brighter future for the island.
Well done. Now, all you need to do is
just fill the gaps yourself and come up
with your own storyline for your next
video. I made a printable version of
this chart to help you plan your stories
even better. It's completely free. You
can download it in description. One last
tip for filling the gaps is just ask
yourself, what do you have in common
with this guy? Well, you're human,
right? Just like him. You can leave your
comfort zone, have an experience, and
transform into a different person. Of
course, you probably don't fight with
literal enemies, but every experience is
worth a story.